mari busca la fracción de bloques rosas
del modelo b
este es nuestro modelo ven que serían
equivalentes a la fracción de bloques
rosas del modelo am este es nuestro
modelo a cuántos bloques del modelo b
deberían ser rosas para que esto pase
vamos primero a contar
vamos a contar primero cuantos bloques
tenemos en el modelo a y para eso
tomaremos un color tenemos 1 2 3 tenemos
un total de tres posibles bloques
cuántos de ellos son rosas pues tenemos
1 y 2
dos de esos tres bloques son rosas dos
tercios si nosotros vamos a buscar la
equivalencia de estos dos tercios en el
modelo b primero vamos a saber cuántas
fracciones tiene este modelo bell y para
eso contaremos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 en el
modelo b tenemos la posibilidad de 9 si
nosotros estamos buscando la
equivalencia de esta fracción dos
tercios vista desde los novenos podemos
ver que aquí se multiplicó tres por tres
el denominador se ha multiplicado por
tres y lo podemos hacer visualmente aquí
sabemos que tanto el modelo a como el
modelo b miden exactamente la misma
distancia lo ven solo que uno está
dividido en tres tercios y otro está
dividido en nueve novenos
nosotros estamos multiplicando tres por
tres ya que cada uno de estos bloques
del modelo a
realmente equivalen a tres bloques del
modelo ven un bloque de la equivale a
123 del b por eso estamos multiplicando
el denominador por 33 por 39 para que
nuestra fracción sea equivalente vamos a
multiplicar también el numerador por
estos 3
por tres será igual a seis
esto nos indica a nivel numérico que dos
tercios es equivalente a seis novenos
para que nuestro modelo b sea
equivalente a nuestro modelo y esto nos
indica que deberíamos de pintar seis de
sus fracciones de color rosa hagámoslo
tendremos
una
4 5 y 6 bloques y tiene sentido se dan
cuenta estos dos tercios equivalen a los
seis novenos que hemos dibujado en el
modelo b vamos a escribir la respuesta
cuántos bloques en el modelo b deberían
de ser rosas para que esto pase deberían
de ser seis bloques y esta será nuestra
respuesta